so i can tell the house that when
parliament returns from recess in the
week commencing
the 22nd of february subject to the full
agreement
of the house mr speaker we intend to set
out the results of that review
and publish our plan for taking the
country
out of lockdown that plan will of course
depend on the continued success of our
vaccination program
the capacity of the nhs and on deaths
falling at the pace we would expect
as more people are inoculated
our aim will be to set out a gradual and
phased approach
towards easing the restrictions in a
sustainable way
guided by the principles we've observed
throughout the pandemic
beginning with the most important
principle of all that reopening schools
must be our national priority and the
first sign of normality
beginning to return should be pupils
going back
to their classrooms i know how parents
and teachers
need as much certainty as possible
including
two weeks notice of the return of
face-to-face teaching
so i must inform the house that for the
reasons i have outlined it will not be
possible
to reopen schools immediately after the
february half term
and i know how frustrating that will be
and will be
for pupils and teachers who want nothing
more
than to get back to the classroom and
for parents and for carers
who spent so many months juggling their
day jobs
not only with with home schooling but
with meeting the
the myriad other demands of their
children from breakfast
until bedtime and i know too the worries
we all share
about the mental health of our young
people during this prolonged period
of being stuck at home so our plan for
leaving the lockdown
will set out our approach towards
reopening
schools if we achieve our target
of vaccinating everyone in the foremost
vulnerable groups with their first
dose by the 15th of february and
every passing day sees more progress
towards that goal
then those groups that have developed
immunity from the virus
about three weeks later that is by
the 8th of march
we hope it will therefore be safe to
begin the reopening of schools
from monday the 8th of march with other
economic and social restrictions being
removed
thereafter as and when the data permits
then or thereafter i should say mr
speaker as we're extending
the period of remote learning beyond the
middle of february
i can confirm that the government will
prolong arrangements for providing free
school meals
for those eligible children not in
school including food parcels and the
national voucher scheme
until they've returned to the classroom
we can also commit now that as we did
this financial year
we will provide a program of catch-up
over the next
financial year and this will involve a
further 300 million pounds of new money
to schools for tutoring and we work in
collaboration with the education sector
to develop as appropriate specific
initiatives
for summer schools and a covid premium
to support catch up but we recognize
that these
extended school closures
have had a huge impact on children's
learning
which will take more than a year to make
up
so we will work with parents teachers
and schools
to develop a long-term plan to make sure
pupils have the chance
to make up their learning over the
course of this parliament